hello there and welcome to this
unusual ai coffee break miss coffee bean
forced me to relax a bit and have more
fun than we usually do in discussing
papers in our
totally serious fashion
yes serious totally serious we have to
be serious it's science
this video starts with a throwback to
this comment of a reddit user about one
of my first
videos with miss coffeebean so someone
on reddit said
that i should ditch the tts
which means that they think i have used
a dds for that video
dts is text to speech let's hear a
snippet from that video is it that bad
hello there in the last video we
outlined
the history of the trench oh i think
that was the wrong audio file because
it really sounded like dts okay now with
the correct audio file
i hope that now that you know about the
transformers success
and proliferation wow i could have
spoken that so much
better but what did i know back then we
were still so young
and you were just a little miss coffee
bean today you're like
two pixels bigger right but
let's stick to that tts a little bit
because there is a reason
why we used exactly the text-to-speech
you heard
it is the default tts packed with nvidia
jarvis
releasing today so let's hear again it's
output because it's
more to it than you first hear and if
you are not very much excited yet
this is the best part about transformers
okay they train very easily with
self-supervision
meaning that they do not necessarily
need annotated training data to be able
to capture human language
there could be some improvements here
and their right but there are also very
good
parts we can blame the good and the bad
parts onto different parts that come
into the tts
and here is where nvidia jarvis comes in
while i was using here the default
models that are
already trained on lots and lots of
training data
the whole jarvis ai is modular such that
you can exchange the parts you are not
content with
with other better ones that you or
someone else
has trained and not only with better
modules but with more
specific ones until you are content with
it
and the whole system is ready to deploy
like i would like to train the tts to
synthesize my voice
and my thick eastern european accent
to speak these videos and you haven't
even heard my eastern european accent
yet
my ultimate goal is to make miss coffee
bean fully sentient
but because i do not want to train those
better or specific modules from scratch
nvidia has got me covered since you can
take the existing models and fine tune
them
in the transfer learning toolkit on your
own data to make it better fit
your style or you know your customers if
you have any
then you can deploy it with jarvis which
optimizes the models and makes them fast
for exactly the gpu
you are using such that your deployed
models can work
real time and it's really easy to set up
it only took letita like a whole day to
get it to run
while i sat in the coffee roaster the
whole time
no kidding leticia just needed a whole
day to figure out that 8 gigabytes of
vram are not enough for some of the
bigger natural language understanding
modules of jarvis
and while nvidia kindly offered to
provide a bigger gpu
which she did not accept they also let
her know how to get it to run on
her measly 3070 rtx
and afterwards it took only minutes to
set up the text-to-speech functionality
of jarvis for this video
so for the jarvis default text-to-speech
one does not need more than 8 gigabytes
of vram
and it's fact checked and the tts is
just a tiny part of nvidia jarvis it
also comes with speech to text and
natural language understanding modules
that you can combine how you want just
think about the possibilities of
creating
your own applications with that it can
help you transcribe your chat
with another person or tag named
entities
and answer your questions but why are we
so hyped about it
because it's multimodal it comes already
with speech
and language and nvidia promises vision
too and you know how much miss coffee
bean likes multimodality especially
between vision and language
check out her videos about that she has
a playlist
so what are you still doing here
go and try out nvidia jarvis and
build your cool applications with it do
not forget to like and subscribe
okay bye okay bye
you